okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others sorry we're starting
a little later than usual i was
giving a talk to a interesting
conference
and um
so i've been answering other questions
for quite a while here
all right let's take a look at what
we've got for today
um
let's see
the question here from jack
how common is atomic
oxygen in the universe
okay so what is the universe mostly made
of
well
the
mostly the universe is quotes empty
space
in quantum mechanics and in our theories
of physics
quotes empty space isn't really actually
empty at all but in terms of kind of the
things we can normally identify like
molecules and atoms and so on it is
considered empty
there's about altogether in the universe
it's about one hydrogen atom per cubic
meter is the typical
uh content of of of the universe
by far the most common the chemical
elements is hydrogen well helium is
about 25
of the abundance of hydrogen in the
universe and as you go to heavier and
heavier elements the abundance gets ever
smaller
how do how do the elements how does that
abundance arise but what happened is at
the beginning of the universe and the
big bang
there was the universe was extremely hot
and there were kind of all possible
particles were produced
as the universe cooled down
most particles all the unstable
particles just decayed away what got
left over were things like protons and
neutrons electrons
and what eventually happened was that
those protons and neutrons and things
were bouncing around at very high
temperatures running around at very high
speeds and kind of when the when the
music stopped so to speak as the
universe expanded and things cooled down
when the music stopped most protons
hadn't found a partner most protons were
just sort of free-floating and had maybe
and
those free-floating electrons turn into
hydrogen atoms
sometimes they found a partner which was
a neutron or other protons or whatever
and those turn into heavier elements so
the chance to have a heavier element
gets ever smaller because
at the time when kind of the music
stopped when the universe expanded to
the point where it was uh cold enough
that these things would not be typically
running into each other they there was a
question sort of how many protons had
accumulated together and so you see this
if you look at the different chemical
elements you'll see this distribution of
um
of abundances in the universe left over
from the big bang now different chemical
elements also get made in stars and get
made in supernovas which are explosions
of stars those can make heavier and
heavier elements
by processes of nuclear fusion where you
take um uh take nuclei of of
different elements and ram them together
and they stick and that makes a heavier
element but so
the typical
uh situation
is that you will get um
um
a um you'll mostly have these light
elements like hydrogen helium lithium
beryllium and so on the the early
elements in the periodic table are by
far the most common in the universe
and um okay so the question was about
atomic oxygen i don't know what the
actual abundance of oxygen is if you
look at the abundances of different
elements in the universe it's not
actually a uniform distribution it's not
just the bigger the elements the less
abundant it is it's a little bit more
complicated than that some of that is
the result of of nuclear fusion in stars
and some of it is the result of detailed
properties of nuclei and the fact that
certain kinds of nuclei are more stable
than others certain nuclei when when
protons had
ran together and maybe there was some
cluster of 20 protons and a few neutrons
that that would break apart into
particular nuclei and their particular
nuclei that are more stable and so
they're more commonly produced but then
the next question is
when you have just an atomic nucleus
let's say an oxygen nucleus hanging
around with its um
uh eight protons and maybe eight
neutrons or something in it um is that
right for oxygen i think that's right um
the uh
when you have that
there's a question of will it make a
molecule like the most common form of
oxygen for example in our atmosphere is
o2 a pair of oxygen atoms bound together
by sharing electrons that's the most
common form actually in the upper
atmosphere there's also ozone which is
o3 which is a slightly unstable form of
oxygen where three oxygen atoms all
bound together in the same way by
sharing electrons
but so the question of will you get
uh oxygen that hasn't bound together
into o2 to make a um an oxygen molecule
like that
it's sort of a question of how often
does a single oxygen atom find another
oxygen atom to pair up with if if the
oxygen is sufficiently sparse then it
just won't find another oxygen atom to
pair up with to make molecular oxygen
now if you look in space and you ask the
question you just look out in the
universe you say what kind of molecules
are there out there
you know is there is there oxygen is
there water h2o
are there various kinds of hydrocarbons
and so on the answer is that it at first
looks a bit surprising because there are
actually quite big molecules that have
been made in space so to speak
and that can happen
uh perhaps it happens on little grains
of dust
that some atom will land another atom
will land and it will get kind of it
will get uh start sharing electrons with
some existing atom and the whole thing
will make a molecule that will then sort
of float away from that grain of dust
maybe it can happen just an empty space
with mark with atoms running into each
other it's not so clear that the answer
is that you get these comparatively
complicated molecules and when they were
first observed people said oh my gosh
there are all these interstellar
molecules they're actually molecules
that are not that different from
molecules that exist in biological
organisms in some cases and it's like
isn't that remarkable that it's possible
to make those things just in space
and well just because these molecules
are just things that happen when you
just throw atoms together they'll tend
to form these molecules the kind of
distribution of different kinds of
molecules that are formed in space is
really different from the distribution
that are formed in for example
biological systems but still some of the
molecules can be comparatively
complicated
let's see
there's a question here from ide
if temperature and pressure both come
from gas molecules bouncing around with
certain momentum why are the two
different what's the difference between
the two okay that is i think he says
famous last words a comparatively easy
question to answer it's always very
dangerous here whenever i think a
question is easy i i haven't seen some
horrible um
uh trap somewhere in
of thing something which has sort of
seemed obvious to me because i've known
it for 50 years but isn't actually that
obvious but let me give this one a try
so
what is temperature
temperature is the average kinetic
energy
of
molecules for example so kinetic energy
is the energy associated with motion
with molecules moving around and uh it's
the formula is it's a half mv squared
where m is the mass and b is the
velocity that's the kinetic energy
associated with a molecule with anything
actually with any object just running
around a certain speed so temperature
is
associated with the kinetic energy of
molecules it's the energy of motion of
the molecules pressure is associated
with
transfer of momentum by molecules so
pressure
is
you say the the pressure is determined
by if you put walls around the around
the gas
how much will the
gas push outwards on the walls how does
the gas push outwards on the walls well
the answer is these molecules are all
bouncing around and occasionally a
molecule will hit the wall and it'll
bounce off and when the molecule hits
the wall it's going in a certain
direction it will
give momentum to that it will
its momentum will be used to push the
wall in a certain direction and then the
molecule will bounce off the wall and
its momentum will have been let's say
reversed by the presence of the wall so
in other words the molecule is
transferring its momentum to the wall
so what's happening is that
pressure is a measurement of the amount
of momentum that could be transferred by
the gas
across that
across that boundary that corresponds to
the wall
and so
again temperature is just the energy
with which all these things are running
around which for a given
mass of molecule translates into the
speed that the molecule the average
speed that the molecules are moving at
there'll always be a distribution of
speeds it's actually a thing called the
maxwell boltzmann distribution the
speeds are exponentially distributed but
there is an average speed that the
molecules are moving at
and that average speed characterizes the
the temperature of the gas that average
speed also
determines the pressure of the gas
because that pressure well it also is
related to the pressure of the gas
because that average speed also
determines for a single molecule hitting
the wall of the container that
determines how much momentum the
molecule can transfer but there's
another factor the other factor which
determines the momentum that transfer
the pressure is the density of molecules
in the gas so
the the temperature is just the energy
of individual molecules which determines
the speed of molecules it doesn't say
anything about how many molecules there
are in the gas
but the pressure depends also on the
number density of molecules so it
depends also on how many molecules are
there per unit volume in the gas
and so in fact the formula
let's see uh yeah i think the formula
for the um the pressure of a gas
is it's proportional to i think it's
one-third
uh nc square bar so it's it's the um uh
it's
n is the number density that is the
number of molecules per cubic
meter let's say in the gas
and c square bar is the mean square
velocity of mean square speed of the
molecules
so temperature
is proportional to the um
uh let's see the temperature
is well kt
half kt yeah is uh let's see temperature
is proportional to the square of the
speed of the molecules
and the pressure is proportional to the
number density times the square of the
speed of the molecules so the reason
that pressure and temperature can vary
independently is that the the
temperature is determining one factor in
the pressure that is the part that comes
from the speed of the molecules but
there's another factor which is the
number density of molecules
so in in kind of high school physics you
might learn the gas laws that say
pressure times volume equals a constant
times temperature
and if we think a little bit more about
what i've just been saying we could
actually derive those gas laws because
we're saying that the volume of the gas
if we keep a fixed number of molecules
and we change the volume the number
density of the molecules is going to
change so if we halve the volume the
number density of molecules is going to
increase by a factor of two because
they're the same number of molecules in
half the volume so that means that if
the volume is halved that means the
number density increases by a factor of
two and that means if we take the
pressure which is proportional to number
density times the volume
and we change the volume by a factor of
two that pressure times volume will be
we'll keep constant because the um
uh because we're uh
because the uh assuming that assuming
it's what's called adiabatic which means
that we don't change the energy we don't
change the temperature of the gas
um well actually that's a
tricky tricky ticking i i i always say
that these are
that there are that's actually so-called
isothermal keeping the same temperature
um the um
where um uh but that's the reason that
pressure times volume
uh keeping the same temperature is is a
constant is because the pressure is
proportional to the number density which
increases as
the volume uh
as the volume decreases the number
density will increase and that's that's
kind of how one can understand the gas
laws um that determine the sort of
overall pressure and volume and
temperature of a gas
by the way
the thing to say you know the standard
formula is pv equals rt or whatever
where r is a constant
if that formula was the whole story of a
gas you wouldn't have liquids you
wouldn't have refrigeration you wouldn't
have a bunch of other things that
formula is just an approximation that
formula is an approximation that works
when the gas is sufficiently dilute it
assumes that basically gas molecules
just bounce off each other they don't
really interact at all but in real gases
the gas molecules uh when if you if you
kind of squash the molecules down far
enough eventually they're interacting so
much that the gas will condense into a
liquid and the molecules will all kind
of stick together in a gas the molecules
are just sort of separately bouncing
around but as you get closer to the
point where the gas has been either
compressed or the temperature has been
reduced to the point where it becomes a
liquid the the molecules are more and
more uh the interactions between
molecules become more and more important
and those interactions produce a
correction to the gas law and that
correction of the gas law is what
leads to well the fact that you can get
a liquid and also the fact that you can
do refrigeration by
by uh letting gases expand um and as as
the gas expands it's kind of losing
energy because some of its energy is
being spent
in uh
in the interactions between the
molecules and that that
energy that's being kind of absorbed by
interactions between the molecules is
removed from the temperature of the gas
which is how the temperature of the gas
manages to go down and that's
essentially the mechanism by which one
can get for example uh liquid
liquid gases you know you can make
liquid nitrogen or liquid oxygen you can
make air liquid so to speak
that's also the thing that um
if you wonder about like uh you know how
cold can it get on the earth
um one thing is that it takes some uh
you know the minimum temperature is
certainly going to be above the
temperature at which air becomes a
liquid because it sort of takes more
effort to make the air liquid and so
that isn't something that will happen
just by virtue of the way that climate
works in in
in the atmosphere
let's see
um
so ben is asking
how should i educate children
like my experience growing up in order
to give them best potential for any stem
field
well let's see i mean i've got a few
meta things to say
you know
i am
i myself just got interested in science
when i was pretty young and just started
learning all kinds of stuff about it and
for me with my particular turn of mind i
was always like is there a question i
want to know the answer to maybe i can
find out the answer in a book or maybe i
have to go figure out the answer somehow
but i think that the the first sort of
meta thing
is to realize that you know just you can
ask a question
and it's like
it's
you can you know the answer might be
known the answer might not be known
there are questions where the answer
isn't no and and those are okay to ask
too and it's kind of just a an issue of
of what of of just like exploring
as much as possible
what um uh and and trying to understand
what's known and what's not known you
know i think it's it's difficult when
people are like teaching science in an
organized way as opposed to perhaps my
way of trying to do it which one might
not characterize as a systematic and
organized so to speak
is if you imagine the stream of
questions and we see that here in these
um uh in these live streams that people
ask they range from questions where the
answer is knowable by sort of high
school level physics let's say to
questions where for example i know the
answer is not knowing or questions where
yes i've thought about that i know the
the kind of the very edge of research in
that area and maybe i've even figured
out something about it myself but the
the sort of questions when they're asked
by kids for example um and we see that
in these in these live streams
they range across all these different
levels of difficulty of questions and i
think it's a it's an important thing to
kind of uh imagine that one can explore
all of those that's a that's a really
useful thing also just i mean a general
point about education is that there are
lots of facts to know in the world and
you know knowing more facts is super
useful to understand what's going on
even if in the end
what's the most most powerful thing is
to understand principles and methods and
so on those have to be hung on a kind of
framework of facts and it's really worth
learning the facts so to speak to be
able to to sort of go from those to sort
of abstract to principles and methods
and so on now when it comes to more
technical levels of of sort of learning
stem kinds of things i i have to make
the pitch to learn kind of computational
language and to
learn this this giant stack of
technology we've been building for the
past 40 years or so um that
now has turned into things like wall
from language and so on um that are a
way of taking kind of thinking about the
world and thinking about things
computationally and one of the great
things about computational language is
that if you can formulate your questions
in computational language then you
together with the computer have the
chance to be able to answer even
questions that nobody has been able to
answer before and sometimes the you know
the the thing that's really worth
learning is how to formulate those
questions in computational terms in
computational language so that you can
get the computer to help you answer
those questions and then often the
answers you'll get are answers that
literally nobody has ever seen before so
you can discover new things and that's
that's kind of a thrill to be able to do
um so i think those are those are things
that i might say
are
the things i i consider to be useful i i
would say that um
uh
my um
uh efforts here in these live streams to
provide kind of um
uh
well i would say that when we learn
science
there are ways to learn science that are
pretty boring really where you're you're
just learning things which are on a
particular path that never runs into any
difficulties where you're just saying
there's a certain set of things where we
know them well and they all fit together
very nicely and it's kind of a
straightforward story there's an another
way to learn science which has to do
with kind of knowing what's interesting
and kind of looking at the interesting
things and sometimes there will be
sort of places very close to the path of
interesting things where or even on the
path of interesting things where we just
don't know that science is simply not
known yet and i think that there's a
certain tendency when one teaches
science in kind of a school setting or
something like that to go only on the
path where it's all very safe and where
everything is known
but i think that it is much more
exciting to understand the path of
science that includes things where one
has to say well i'm sorry we just don't
know that yet
um and uh and not to be afraid of those
kinds of things even though it doesn't
work so well you know if you have the
multiple choice test or something that
says uh um you know is
the um
uh
what is the size of an electron is it
zero 10 to the minus 93 meters 10 to the
minus 20 meters or whatever well we just
don't know the answer so there's no kind
of multiple choice you know check box
that can be filled out yet
nobody knows that yet
as a question here from reed
um
if i were in my 20s young 20s and just
graduated from college which field would
i go into ai and machine learning
aerospace engineering blockchains and
crypto
and so on
um
you know it's a very personality
dependent thing
you can go into their they're always at
any given time there's a field that's
kind of in rapid growth
and it lasts maybe five or ten years
that that rapid growth happens
if you want to kind of run with the pack
and really try and you know do things
around this pack of people who are all
rushing in the same direction
then you should go into these fields
that are popular at any given time if on
the other hand you want to kind of be
more relaxed and just
you say i'm going to do something
original but
it doesn't have to be something where
there's a whole pack of people going in
that same direction then you can go into
a much sleepier field and go and do
something great and innovative in that
field you won't have any competitors
you'll have to explain to people why
what you've done is important but it's a
much sort of calmer life in some sense
right now the areas i i would say my own
feeling is of the ones you mentioned um
you know ai and machine learning i i
kind of think
that has been something where there's
sort of a new methodology that came in
maybe 10 years ago now
that has unlocked a bunch of kinds of
computational approaches i think we're
seeing the end of the period of rapid
growth for that particular uh area um
we're not seeing the end of the
applications of that area there will be
applications forever and there will be
an increasing number of increasingly
useful applications probably but it is
the the sort of the early kind of
pseudo-basic science side of it i think
that's pretty well worked through at
this point and we're really into the
kind of the these the sort of
engineering applications type phase
right now um and it's it's going to be a
slower growth story
uh aerospace engineering you know when i
was a kid i was interested in space and
there was 1960s and space was a big
thing and i i actually got interested in
physics first by being interested in
things like spacecraft and i was
thinking how would you design a
spacecraft to do this or that
i'm really glad i didn't decide to spend
my life doing spacecraft because the
world has just not been in a place where
spacecraft have been sort of a happening
thing until very recently um i don't i
you know one of the things which will i
think be a
um a determiner of what happens in the
sort of the new space
period
is it's clear
that it will become ever easier to sort
of put things in space and then the real
question is so what's the point
what's that going to be good for you
know there was a time in the 1960s for
example 50s and 60s when exploring the
oceans was like this is the the
absolutely the thing you know submarines
and all that kind of thing it's going to
be great there are going to be cities
under the ocean and so on um and uh that
didn't happen um and you know there's
going to be oh we're going to be able to
do mining in the ocean we're going to be
able to do this that or the other in the
et cetera in the ocean that didn't
happen
now in in space you know what will the
moon colony be for
it's not clear yet at least not to me
once we kind of but things may very well
emerge really good things really
interesting things may emerge
and you know the whether it's satellite
imagery uh which emerged in the early
period of of space whether it's
communications
those kinds of things those are those
are things we now know are going to be
things in space but we don't know what
else will emerge we don't know what else
will turn out to be important i mean
there was a time when people said that
growing perfect crystals in the in the
zero gravity conditions of in orbits and
things would be really important that
hasn't panned out yet but we don't
really know yet so i think the jury is
still out in terms of what will be kind
of the the evolution of of space so to
speak in space uh spacecraft and so on
in um in what comes now you said
aerospace in general um you know that's
another interesting question will it be
the case that there are dramatic
innovations whether it's
hydrogen-powered planes whether it's um
uh whether it's electric planes whether
it's supersonic planes will those be
things that become a uh
a significant part of the landscape or
not you know there was a time when i was
younger when the concord was was
supersonic plane was thought to be yeah
this is the future this is really
everybody's going to be taking
supersonic flights i'm happy to say i
took one flight on the concorde it was
it was fun um it's uh i had some
particular time when i was in london and
i needed to be in new york shortly
thereafter and i thought what the heck i
will splurge and take a flight on the
concord it was it was kind of fun to to
um uh the physics of it was interesting
to me you know it flew high enough fifty
thousand fifty five thousand feet maybe
that the that the sky which is normally
blue from uh uh from scattering of of um
of sunlight in the atmosphere it's black
at those at those heights um during the
even during the day so that was that was
a fun feature the other fun feature is
uh you know i i've studied uh sort of
some
supersonic uh uh
motion through fluids and so on and it's
kind of fun to actually feel
what it's like to sort of break the
sound barrier and so on and the way it
was in the concord they had this big big
thing at the front of the cabin where
they had a um uh you know a speed meter
because after all you were paying for
the fact that you were going really fast
so they had to show how fast you were
going but mark one is is defined to be
the speed of sound and so there was a
you could kind of see the typical plane
might might fly at mach point nine or
something mark 0.85 0.9 that kind of
thing the the reason one doesn't want to
fly
at
reason it's hard to fly faster than the
speed of sound is that there are shock
waves that develop around a plane when
when the plane is going faster than the
speed of sound essentially all of the
sound waves that are produced by the
plane moving through the air all build
up and form the shop front it's kind of
like if you if you ride a bicycle
through a puddle you'll see this kind of
wall of water that comes from behind the
sort of in this cone or this this um uh
behind your
where your bicycle wheel goes and that's
that's kind of a shock which comes from
all these little water waves that were
produced by the the effect of your
bicycle they all kind of pile up at that
particular
at that particular place and it's the
same thing with with sound waves and
that that piling up of sound waves
produces
a um a variety of different ways to see
it it produces a discontinuity and
pressure in in the in the air and so on
and it's something which is is uh
produces lots of stress
on the uh on the uh on the structure of
the plane actually there's another
phenomenon which is right when you get
towards the sound barrier but toward
when you get towards the speed of sound
there is an instability that starts
happening in the flow of air over the
wings of a plane so normally the air is
you know when that when the
when the wing
goes slices through the air the air goes
above the wing below the wing and the
the wing is kind of slicing through the
air
when
and the the air flows kind of smoothly
over the top of the wing or the bottom
of the way but right near the speed of
sound a strange phenomenon happens that
causes there to be an instability
in the air and the air kind of forms
this kind of wave that uh sort of uh
oscillates
on on the wing and the fact that the
place where the where the air kind of
separates away from the wing uh kind of
that that front oscillates around and
that leads to this kind of um
this leads to this instability and
that's what when people tried in the
1950s to uh to first have planes that
flew faster than the speed of sound the
planes kept on falling apart or
otherwise failing because of this the
the kind of all this instability that
happened from the flow of air over wings
right around the uh around mark 1. well
it was kind of interesting uh my one
trip on the concord to kind of feel that
instability uh you could kind of feel
the thing kind of juttering around um
and you could also see that it was just
below the speed of sound it was it was
pushing pushing pushing and it was um
and its engines were running so to speak
and it was took a little bit of effort
more effort to get over the speed of
sound and then after it got through
speed of sound it could it could
accelerate fairly rapidly um and that
was just sort of an interesting thing to
to feel the physics so to speak in that
case
but the question of whether it will turn
out to be the case that things like
supersonic planes electric planes things
like this become uh popular uh you know
that's as much a societal and and
complicated engineering question as
anything else for example drones
which um for example particularly
quadcopter drones um where you know the
idea of those that existed for 50 years
it just hadn't been possible to
implement them because the particular
technologies to do with the flight
controllers that were the control system
that
it wasn't possible to have the right
kind of computers it wasn't possible to
have the battery density to be able to
run the electric motors in in such a way
that the batteries weren't too heavy to
lift all those kinds of things those
various engineering uh sort of curves
had to align to the point where it was
possible to uh to do something
and you know so now drones exist
uh you know will supersonic planes uh
exist again
um not clear possibly yes possibly
another 50 years
will people care about it when they
exist
you know back in the day
when i would go on a on i would have to
drive in a car a long distance it's like
i can't do that that's way too boring
you know i can't spend three hours
driving that's like horrifying or what
am i going to do with for three hours
well now of course then there were cell
phones and now you know i i don't mind
going on a long drive because i've got
phone calls i want to make and things
like that and i'm kind of happily doing
things similarly
you know going on a longer plane trip
it's like well i just get out my
computer and i start doing what i would
normally do and i'm connected to the
internet and it's all good i'm just like
i've got a nicer view out of the window
and it doesn't really matter to me so
much whether i'm going at a supersonic
speed and able to cross the atlantic in
you know two hours instead of five or
something so these things that are
determined by sort of human effects of
does it you know how much do people
really care about going to getting to
their destination that much faster um
you know maybe there's a use case where
that's really important maybe it's
important for something but i'm not sure
that people will care as much as they
once you know for example this
phenomenon of i don't mind driving a
long distance because i can do something
like be on a phone call um is it just
wasn't something i might have expected
it's just another piece of technology
that sort of converged and so i don't
know what the future of aerospace will
be from that point of view it seems like
an exciting area right now where a
combination of sort of the push for
clean energy versus the fact that
there's sort of commercialization of
space and so on these seem like things
that are driving a lot of interesting
possibilities there what will turn out
to be societally useful or cared about
is a little bit harder me to predict
now you asked about blockchains and
crypto that's definitely a very
energetic area um that's an area that i
think is is pretty interesting because
it's kind of an area where it's forcing
a rethinking of a lot of things that we
imagine now is it a you know in a sense
a blockchain so you know the idea of
blockchain the earliest being bitcoin
the blockchain is sort of two different
ideas all merged together
one idea is the idea that you can have
this kind of ledger this thing that says
what happened you say this event
happened this thing happened let's let's
put that in our ledger and let's arrange
that ledger to be in this chain of
blocks
where the the we guarantee that every
block we add guarantees that all the
previous blocks are correct
and i could explain maybe i did once
before i can explain in in great detail
how that works but essentially the idea
is you're adding more and more blocks
you're adding more and more things that
you can put on this blockchain and when
you add a block you're guaranteeing that
everything in the past is accurate so
let's say you're trying to record who
owns that house
and you say i'm going to put that on the
blockchain and it's it's there it's it's
and everybody can and people can see it
on the blockchain but you guarantee as
you add more things to the blockchain
you guarantee nobody can change that
thing that was earlier on the blockchain
you can't sort of take out that brick
and have the rest of the of the
structure remain intact
so that's kind of the the important idea
of blockchain is is this kind of ledger
that builds up and the other important
idea is that it's a distributed ledger
in the sense that there are many copies
of it like for for bitcoin there might
be 10 000 copies of the ledger around
the world and they're always those
things are always kept um kept uh
consistent um again long story exactly
how that works but basically the point
is that there are these many copies
maybe 10 000 maybe more copies of that
ledger and so it's not possible for
somebody to say i'm just going to change
it i'm going to adjust it it's something
where it's a sort of permanent record in
the world that's one thing one
application of that is to money because
if you want to know if you say well i've
got this coin and i want to um
say i'm going to i own this number of
coins
and i've got the information that i own
this number of coins is on the
blockchain and then i give one of these
coins to somebody else and that
transaction is on the blockchain so now
that person has a coin and i have one
less coin and so on and you're recording
all of this information on the
blockchain that's kind of the the idea
there now what gets more elaborate is
that you can have not just transactions
in which you just you know somebody pays
somebody with one coin but you can
actually have programs that run for
example on the blockchain
that um
are specifying that i don't know
um
uh that that
you know you have some lottery let's say
where people put money in and then the
program running on the blockchain will
just randomly pick one of those people
to pay out all the money to let's say
that turns into probably a yet more
interesting idea which is the idea of
computational contracts
the idea that you can have normally when
you have a legal contract it's written
down in in words and so on it says you
know one person if if a gives b a
hundred dollars then b will mow their
lawn or something um and that's what the
contract says and it's in words
but you can have a computational
contract which is says is a program that
says uh you know if this computer
receives this money then this camera
will check that the lawn got mowing and
if it didn't then this will happen and
that will happen and so on and it's all
something defined computationally and
that's really a thing that has just
starting these days to be a big thing
that sort of turning the way that the
the world is specified into these
computational contracts that have to be
written in kind of a computational
language now that is overlaps with the
whole world of blockchain but it isn't
quite the same thing you can have
computational contracts not using
blockchain you can have blockchain not
using sophisticated computational
contracts but the combination of those
things is kind of a redefinition of how
a lot of kinds of business processes a
lot of kinds of things in the world
actually work
so i mean i would have to say that i
think there's great sort of very diverse
collection of different things that are
happening around the blockchain and
crypto world it is a strange world
because you know if you look at these
different fields if you look at ai and
machine learning you look at aerospace
engineering look at blockchains you ask
what kinds of people with what kinds of
skills are going into these fields well
ai and machine learning it's a bunch of
people going through computer science
departments a bunch of people with
physics backgrounds because a lot of the
mathematical analysis is very
physics-based that's a and there's also
quite a lot of kind of engineering
software engineering type
almost hackery that goes on around that
kind of thing so that's that's one type
of person when it comes to aerospace
engineering you really have to be an
engineer to do that well there are
strategy kinds of things that can be
done otherwise but you really have to be
an engineer thinking about things in an
engineering kind of way and imagining
you know how would we make this wing
curl in this way and this this thing
work in that way and if if you're just a
programmer for example it's a little bit
less of a thing where you can really
make a contribution you really have to
know the engineering to make a
contribution there in the world of
blockchain and crypto it's interesting
because
it's a very general field and if you
know about if you just have some
strategic idea and you know about
finance or you know about physics or you
know about mathematics so you know about
computer science you know about program
verification all these different fields
of relevance to the the picture of
what's happening in blockchain and
crypto it's also the case that the the
sort of the educational backgrounds of
people in that area very diverse if you
look at people in aerospace they will
have studied aerospace engineering it's
very unlikely that you'll have somebody
there maybe they've studied physics but
but they won't have been
somebody who did you know art history
and then and then decided to build
supersonic planes that's not a that's
not a common path whereas in blockchain
and crypto there's just tremendously
diverse educational and in fact cultural
and other backgrounds that people have
coming into this blockchain area and it
creates a rather interesting uh kind of
melting pot uh kind of field where there
are lots of opportunities um there's
also a fair amount of nonsense there
and that's you know that's a that's a
place where if you're in a field where
there's a fair amount of technical
knowledge that's needed to really enter
the field it tends to be a much narrower
story in terms of there's great stuff
there's not so great stuff but it isn't
it's all reasonably sensible whereas if
there's a field where there isn't much
of a barrier to entry and it's kind of
just like if you choose to get into the
field you can do it there can be total
nonsense and really wonderful stuff and
they're both kind of populating that
field but i would say that that um it's
a field where there's a lot of
opportunity for blockchains and crypto
is a field where there's just sort of a
lot of opportunity for uh thinking about
all kinds of different things now will
you be successful in that field
sometimes uh because there's this it's
not as narrow a kind of definition of
what success looks like some of these
things depend on societal factors some
of them depend on kind of predicting uh
kind of how people
react to things and so on it's it's a
field where it's sometimes a little bit
harder to know what's going to come out
based on what you put in but i think
it's a very
energetic and active field that's also
very intellectually interesting because
it mixes oh all sorts of things about
kind of computational contracts which
have to do with kind of ai-ish sort of
computational language questions uh have
to do with sort of the
the how you think about law and
computational terms things like this
together with things like um uh
verifying how
how that uh the blockchain can never
cause one to double spend a coin or
something that's a whole story of kind
of uh program verification together with
all sorts of things about how different
kinds of business processes work um it's
it's really a an area where there's a
lot of diverse
um kinds of things to be thought about a
little bit like what happened with early
social media social networks and so on
um where again it was something where
you know the raw technology was a piece
of it but there were a lot of other
factors that came in i would say
blockchain is a broader area than that
but it has some of the same kind of
character to it
let's see
question um
from aaron
is there a closest packing for spikey
spikeys are these things i don't know i
probably got one behind me there let's
see i actually have a paper one here
this is the this was the model spikey
that was made by my older daughter years
ago that um we we were creating spiky
kits and this was the uh the test spikey
that was made for for one of those spiky
kits which i happen to have on the shelf
here but anyway this is a spiky and the
question that was being asked is um is
there a way of packing these things
together
and the answer is they don't pack
as a tiling of all space but you can
pack them
you can make various kinds of linear
packings of them
you have to have
boy i should know this i even wrote a
long piece about it um
you have to have
uh other
you can't fill space just with spikeys
you have to have another another piece
uh as well to be able to just sort of
fill up space with them you're asking
what's the largest and smallest spiky i
think there are some very small ones
that exist
in a strange kinds of crystals
crystalline materials
some kinds of lanthanum manganese
something compounds that form little uh
quasi crystals that are that kind of
shape so that's that's something which
will be um
uh maybe um
uh
a hundred millionth of a meter across
something like that
the largest spiky i've ever seen well
i've seen pictures of pretty big spikeys
i saw one somebody made that was um
about uh a few times the height of a
person so that's a fairly large spiky um
i'm not sure i've i've seen um
somehow i i think that was a there's a
a strange event that i've never been to
called burning man that's a it's a
kind of a strange uh sort of festival in
the desert where all sorts of terrible
things happen but um uh i believe people
have made sort of spiky-like ornaments
ornaments
for that that are pretty big but i don't
think i'm guessing on the order of i
don't know
20 30 feet across so that's probably the
largest i've seen
um
let's see i should uh
wrap up fairly soon here um
let's see
it's questions about
uh from reed about
will we see agi this century
so what is agi agi is artificial general
intelligence what does that mean
well
you know when i started knowing about
artificial intelligence kinds of things
probably now what 50 years ago now
people would say as soon as computers
can do x y or z
then they'll be intelligent they'll be
just like humans
so what were x y and z there were things
like as soon as computers can do math
like humans do it as soon as computers
can
drive cars like humans can do it as soon
as computers can recognize images like
humans do it then they'll be intelligent
well each of these kinds of things has
been able to be done by computers but
people say well but i can see inside i
can see how the computer does math and
it's not really intelligent it's just
using algorithms and programs to do math
but well that was the test and computers
passed that
now another test is can you have a
conversation with a computer and not
know
that you're talking to a computer rather
than to a person that's often called the
turing test for intelligence invented by
alan turing in 1950 um this this idea of
if you if you're talking to a thing and
you wonder is it a computer is it a
person maybe you can't tell the
difference you know i have to say just
yesterday
uh somebody sent me something which was
a computer-generated conversation
and it was a computer
that had learnt from
a bunch of examples billions of words of
of actual conversation of actual text on
the web and elsewhere and it
kind of learnt the pattern of different
kinds of conversation and so on and its
goal was to simulate a real conversation
and so this person had taught it based
on a bunch of texts perhaps some
transcripts of these live streams um
had taught it to talk like me and so i
was really curious what would it what
would it be like what would this machine
generated ai generated thing that's like
me be like it was awful
just awful it was uh you know in an
individual sentence by individual
sentence basis the sentences were
grammatical uh which is good i hope my
sentences are usually grammatical
um and but it was uh it couldn't sort of
maintain a thought it couldn't maintain
a thread of thought it was just sort of
throwing out random sentences
far away from the kinds of things that
that we humans end up talking about so
that's a place where people say look we
haven't reached artificial general
intelligence because we can't have like
a conversation with a computer like that
but one of the things that's tricky
is to say
you have to kind of contextualize what
kind of a conversation would you like to
have
if you're trying to
you know book a plane ticket or
something well that's a that's a very
it's a conversation with a very specific
objective
and that's not out of range for what can
be done today in fact there are systems
that do a pretty good job of that kind
of thing if you want to have a free
ranging let's talk about anything you
feel like talking about well what are
you going to talk to the computer about
you can say how do you feel today to the
computer
well how does a computer feel today hard
to know that's a difficult question to
answer you know computers don't have the
same kinds of experience of the world
that we do if you give a computer sort
of
if you have the computer walking around
with you and kind of experiencing the
world like you experience it well then
perhaps you can have a conversation in
which the computer is like well you know
my my owner so long as computers have
owners which they will for a while um
you know my owner thinks this that and
the other you know it's kind of i've
been i've been walking around with them
and um uh you know this is their
experience and now i can as a computer
talk about their experience like it's my
own type thing
and so
you know this question of when will we
get to the point where you can have
a
i mean that's really the last frontier i
think is this kind of when can we have a
conversation with the computer like we
can with a person um and i think you
know in limited cases that's not far
away
the real question for an ai
is what does the ai want to do
us humans
have our own strange motivations for why
we want to do this or that
which come from our own personal history
the history of our whole culture the set
of values we have all kinds of things
like this those are the overarching
things that determine what we choose to
do
and this question about how do you set
goals that's not something where we can
say well let's automate setting goals
what would be the automatic goals that
are set well you'd have to say what's
the goal of the goals so to speak you
don't know there's no sort of ultimate
mathematically defined goal that you
should have maybe one possibility is to
say don't go extinct
because if you go extinct you're not
going to have any goals at all but even
that you might not you might argue about
whether that's the right goal for the ai
is the don't go extinct goal maybe it's
not the right goal maybe if the humans
want to be in charge it's not the right
goal to have the ais be absolutely dead
set on not going extinct
so you know it's it's a thing where in
the end the goals have to be the goals
are not precisely defined the goals are
not abstractly defined the goals are
just defined by what we humans choose to
make the goals and so that's something
that that no
agi so to speak is going to determine
its own goals because it doesn't even
make it doesn't make sense to think
about that
um things do what they do like
things in the world things and you know
the weather does what it does
and you could say well it looks as if
it's having goals to do this or that but
actually it just does what it does and
and we also operate according to
physical laws and just do what we do but
we have at least this idea that we have
definite goals and so on and and that's
just not something that you can
translate
to it just doesn't mean anything to
translate that to this other thing
that's this ai you have to give it the
goals so to speak you can't it can't be
the ultimate source of those goals
so i think in that sense it's it's now
sometimes the goals can be far removed
from what the ai is actually doing i
mean a famous example of that is you
know the ais that determine sort of the
ordering of content in social media or
in search engines and so on the question
is what is the goal of that ai well the
goal might be maximize revenue for the
by by making content be something where
people will engage with it as much as
possible click on the ads as much as
possible whatever else that might be the
the ultimate goal of the of the ai as
defined by the company that's running
the ai but what that actually means in
terms of what the actual content that
comes out in this in this uh stream is
well that's a complicated story and for
example the ai has has discovered i mean
this is a fact that the ai has
discovered that the more outrageous the
content is the more likely people are to
click on it and read it and and engage
with it so that means the ai even though
that wasn't the original goal
on the parts of sort of the humans who
are setting the ai up to maximize ad
revenue that still is the consequence is
it turns out humans have this feature
that they're more likely to engage with
outrageous content so there's more
outrageous content that's generated
there and so that's that's kind of a a
feature of the ai where where i suppose
in some sense it's it's operating in a
in a in a general intelligence kind of
way um just uh you know doing those
kinds of things given its overall goal
so i would expect that what we'll see
in terms of ai is
we'll see more and more kind of
symbiosis between us humans and ai when
augmented reality becomes common which
will finally happen after many years of
it not happening we'll we'll regularly
be seeing sort of annotations to our
everyday life uh generated by ai so
right now you know if in some time in
the future my my glasses will probably
have something which is producing some
augmented reality thing and it's it's
reminding me about all kinds of stuff oh
you should say this oh you know that
connects with this thing that you've
thought about before those are ways that
we will kind of share our experience
with ais and meanwhile the ai that is
connected with me will be learning from
the things that i'm saying and doing and
eventually it'll say you know you really
like doing this or that thing i've
noticed that when you do this or that
thing then whatever happens and so i
think there'll be sort of increasing
symbiosis between us uh and and uh and
the ais that we're connected to and i
think eventually the line will somewhat
blur between what is kind of the the
pure human activity and what is the ai
helping the human that's already
happened to some extent i mean when
whenever we uh sort of follow the um
auto suggestions when we're typing
things into a computer whenever we
follow a gps in a car or something we're
kind of letting the ai
determine some of what's happening and
we're kind of we're kind of operating in
this way that's in
in collaboration with the ai
let's see um well we should probably
wrap soon here maybe one
more
question
um
all right we'll try one more here
uh
one more this was about um
from memes asking what's the deal with
superfluids
any useful purposes
okay what is a superfluid
so
normally
if you have some water for example and
you
put your hand in the water and you swirl
the water around you'll make this kind
of vortex the water will be going around
in a circle but it won't take long
before the water will sort of calm down
and the motion that you put into the
water will just sort of decay away and
the water will be will be um still again
the what causes that that kind of
stopping emotion is the phenomenon of
viscosity
um viscosity is is kind of a a damping
of motion in it's kind of like an analog
of friction
friction between solids kind of the
analog of that inside of fluid is
viscosity
and some fluids have higher viscosity
than others if you have syrup for
example you can have very high viscosity
it doesn't like to flow very much
whereas if you have other fluids they'll
they'll um uh and in in syrup treacle
and british english um you you'd have if
you start off some motion will very
quickly decay away um in water the
viscosity is lower and so it will take
longer for the motion to die away
okay so a question is are there any
fluids that have zero viscosity can you
have a liquid that has zero viscosity
will you start this vortex going it will
just keep going for days weeks years
the answer is yes there are there are so
called superfluids
and what is a superfluid so the most
common example of a superfluid is liquid
helium-4
helium-4
when i say helium-4 i mean it's helium
where there two protons and two neutrons
in the nucleus of that helium
atom
so what happens is when you cool
helium-4
below a certain temperature around uh
four degrees above absolute zero i think
um it becomes a superfluid
so what happens when when you cool
something down the molecules we talked
about this actually earlier in this live
stream the temperature corresponds to
the motion the speed at which molecules
are running around as you cool something
down the molecules get slower and slower
and slower but most of the time there's
still
even when you get to absolute zero of
temperature where the molecules uh
shouldn't be moving around at all there
are quantum effects that cause them to
be some there to be some motion in the
molecules
but
there are cases in which
there is enough essentially
interaction between molecules that even
that zero point energy at absolute zero
gets essentially removed and this
happens
superfluids are essentially the analog
of lasers in fluids so in a laser you've
got all these photons and the photons
are all collected together in such a way
that they photons like to do the same
thing as each other so if you if you get
photons set up in the right way they'll
all like to go at the same frequency in
the same direction the same phase and
that's why this laser is sort of
coherent piece of light
the the the photons they're so called
boson particles and the bosons have this
feature that they all like to be in the
same state and that can happen with
helium-4 atoms as well
that they can all want to be in the same
state so that these helium 4 atoms sort
of collectively do things they all you
know vote together so to speak to do
something and that means that when you
start up motion in helium-4 and when
it's a superfluid that motion all the
atoms just keep doing what their friends
were doing so to speak and that means
that you kind of keep this motion going
there's no possibility of having that
little bit of friction that little bit
of viscosity that will slow the motion
down and so that means that in a
superfluid you will have a motion that
will just keep going no viscosity and so
that means that you can have these
circulations and superfluids that just
keep flowing forever
and um uh that they've been made to do
that for years actually if you keep
things cold enough they'll just keep
flowing keep flowing um and uh
that um
um
that's that's the um
that's the way that works now the
question was are there useful purposes
for superfluids and i'm wondering about
the answer to that question
because i am not immediately thinking of
one
um superfluid that it was discovered
nearly 100 years ago maybe even a little
bit more than 100 100 years ago now um
and uh
oh gosh what are the uses for
superfluids
um
there are some ways of doing
refrigeration
that to very very low temperatures that
use actually they use
mostly versions of helium that don't
um
that aren't super fluidic
uh gosh
i don't know
it's a wonderful phenomenon i mean
superconductivity
which is the ability of electrons to
sort of flow without friction to just
keep flowing in a wire superconductivity
is useful as a way to be able to have uh
larger amounts of current to make
stronger magnets used in most uh well in
in particle accelerators some mri
machines things like that to be able to
have stronger magnets unfortunately the
problem with superconductivity and
superfluidity is that both of them
require very low temperatures and that's
just a big nuisance to deal with
let's see i'm i'm wondering whether
people have tried to make quantum
computers out of superfluids and i don't
think that they have although i think
it's something you could imagine doing
um
i'm uh
i'm blanking on this i i'm not thinking
of any
uh of any applications of superfluids
um let me think
uh
can i even imagine applications of
superfluids
um
see it's a big nuisance that they have
to be within a few degrees of absolute
zero so that makes it kind of hard
to to have them exist um
i am not immediately coming up with any
application at all
um which is so that's a that's a thing
for the future so to speak for physics
is uh you know a lot of phenomena like
when liquid crystals were discovered um
you know back in the 1800s i don't think
anybody knew that they would have an
application and of course they were used
for a long time in displays even still
used in displays for computers and so on
um but uh uh so i don't know in the case
of superfluids good question i have to
think about that one
all right we should probably wrap up
here um thanks a lot for those
interesting questions
and uh next week we should be back to
our regularly scheduled time
thanks for joining us here